[Musique]
bonsoir beau soit
je demande si je vais descendre chez mme
et m mais oui nounours qui en a très
envie je laissais bon je descends mais
je vous confie mon chapeau patron tenez
comme ça cornichons les juliette pas ne
me le prendre on pas je te le gardes
sois sans crainte merci mon échelle
c'est cette casquette que je préfère et
moi j'aime mieux le chapeau de cowboy et
moi j'en ai un comme celui nounours bon
chapeau à l'eau t'agites pas nounours et
pas tiens c'est un cul mur semble mais
oui ragga de sa mallette dans les
magasins et nous avons acheté pita
chapeaux et des bras et des cascades
touchant mais pourquoi fort pour mon
papa ma maman pour daddah et celui là
pour julietta
au chili et à que tu es mignonne
et pour nounours alors moi aussi
j'aimerais avoir un chapeau m
j'en voudrais un nom à la regarde de ce
quart temps c'est pour moi mais oui on
l'a acheté pour toi on est gentil
[Musique]
on lan un chapeau de forme
qu'il est pour quelques temps je suis le
plus heureux de tous les lots 6 le plus
haut vive notre nounou
à la vive notre nounours
ouais j'ai eu le temps et les parties ce
tram est beau avec son chapeau nov ça
m'ennuie calais coquelles
je vais essayé de la rattraper allez
vite au lit je m'occupe de mademoiselle
juliette à
[Musique]
bali nous
je ne devais pas julietta vous ne l'avez
pas vu pas trop non
aulas coquines ou est elle perçue allons
plus loin nous la retrouverons peut-être
oui en route bonne nuit les petits
embrasser bien fort vos parents le fait
de beau
jeu le temps julio tas
[Musique]
oh